bonjour david expliquez-nous qu'est ce
qui suscite le mécontentement des agents
de la police scientifique et bien sophie
c'est leur statut inquiets et en colère
les agents de la police technique et
scientifique
un statut de sédentaires qu'il voudrait
transformer un statut d'actif comme
leurs collègues de la police nationale
un chiffre à vous donner 30 % des
enquêtes nationales sont résolus grâce à
la police scientifique et technique
voilà le statut d'actif permet à la
police nationale de partir plus tôt en
retraite ou d'avoir en tout cas des
droits acquis sont plus prêts publics et
privilégié pour la police nationale que
la police scientifique et technique et
un paradoxe également c'est que depuis à
10 ans la police scientifique et
technique doit porter un gilet pare
balles sur les scènes de crime
ce qui est assez paradoxal puisqu'il
n'ont pas d'armes de service et non pas
le même statut que la police nationale
je vous propose d'écouter george s nach
membres du sni pattes
un syndicat de la police scientifique et
technique
plus on avance dans le temps et plus la
police scientifique à des contraintes
particulières puisque je rappelle qu'on
est sur un statut de des années 90 qui
est un statut des techniques de
laboratoire depuis l'emploi a énormément
changé
on met des contraintes de plus en plus
sur les collèges des astreintes de nuit
des dvd des contraintes horaires des
contraintes de pénibilité de dangerosité
en intervention sur terrain et derrière
ça suit pas donc il y en a un peu ras le
bol on a des collègues on a explosé avec
le dossier retraites puisque voilà les
collègues on se rend compte qu'ils vont
devoir travailler jusqu'à 65 67 ans à
faire de la constatation sur des
cadavres sur les scènes de crime
pour des retraites misérables de 1300 à
1400 euros par mois on a des collègues
il a ici qui ont plus de 60 ans qui sont
avec nous aujourd'hui et c'est un
véritable lavage véritable drame pour
ces gens le cortège fit son cours
jusqu'à la place saint-augustin c'est là
que la dispersion aura lieu ils sont
entre 150 et 200 à s'être réunis un pour
cette manifestation d'ordre national il
ya des policiers qui viennent du sud
ouest du nord et des policiers un
scientifique évidemment un parisien la
revendication je vous le disais donc
pour obtenir ce statut
un d'actifs et ne plus avoir ce statut
est sédentaire les négociations et
dernières négociations avec le
gouvernement n'ont rien donné il espère
bien se faire entendre
aujourd'hui beaucoup pour toutes ces
explications david khalifa